[música]
tal con Crimea
El jarabe llegó a Kiev cuando tenía 19 años.
ahora tengo 34 años mis padres vinieron
inmediatamente excepto
sami vino a rusia yo papa crimea
tártaro y diría que lo harás
allí desde Rusia
aburrir saber que los transportistas esconden sus
sentimientos y esa es una calle
no fumes mama me parece que
chica inteligente
pero
[música]
quiero moverme para esconderme
por 6k ser algo de tiempo muy
lo que podemos trinidad
[música]
entonces amigos siglo 21
Sótano de la ciudad de Kherson
la mayoría aquí ya han dado a luz a todo el
niños pequeños y aquí tenemos 2
en camino
di hola por favor
[música]
muy 10 cm
come
[música]
todo lo que quiero decir es que xii relación
muy eficiente esta es esa generacion
lo que crece ya sera con odio
5 a este país, eso es exactamente un hecho
en general, sí, diablos sabe cómo lo quiero
que Rusia sea la última en negarse
enfermedad o afectado la mitad de la torre
manera
el Ministerio de Relaciones Exteriores de Ucrania esas son nuestras tierras
[música]